Search crews in Nepal have
recovered the remains of all
but one victim of Sunday's
deadly plane crash.
We are now seeing video
purportedly from inside
from a passenger inside
the plane just moments before th
I'm Audie Cornish.
Now, we've edited the video
so you can not identify
anyone who was on the plane.
We're also not showing you
the moment it crashes,
but this video could help
authorities determine
what led to the crash.
There were 72 people on board,
including four crew members,
when it crashed into a gorge.
Seen as video consumed joins us
You've been covering this.
Nepali authorities,
they dispute this video.
Why
John, before we get to that,
I think it's important for our a
to know
that CNN
has corroborated
this video based on the flight m
We've looked into
information on the website
of the Yeti Airlines
and also we've used geo location
Now, the Nepali authorities
and we are talking
about the spokesperson
of the Civil Aviation
Authority in Nepal
has said, hey,
this video is not from inside
the plane that crashed.
But when we pressed further,
he said he has no technical evid
to support his claim.
However, CNN has also spoken
to aviation experts,
and they say that this could be
a crucial piece of evidence
for the investigators
who have about 45 days
to submit their report
to the Nepal government.
CNN has also spoken
to the passenger's friend.
The passenger was from India.
And we've also spoken
to state officials from the stat
he belonged to in India.
Now, coming to the latest on gro
from the crash site,
all but one body has been recove
Search ops have been called off
for the day
and will resume tomorrow morning
There was a problem
early morning
in Nepal, Carol,
where the crash site
is because of the fog,
but that cleared away
and drones
will use to find the missing pas
Also, another update that we've
is that more than 40 bodies
have reached Kathmandu.
Family
members will be identifying thes
bodies over the next few days
and then these bodies
will be handed over to them.
Another 20 plus bodies
have been handed over to family
in port. Itself.
Now the black boxes were recover
on Monday
and that should throw
and will throw light
on what really happened
inside the cockpit
in the last few moments. John.
All right.
So thank you so much.